Hey whoo I am still not used to
presenting in a large space like this so
feel free to hoot and holler cuz I do
ten yes yes because I do tend to feed
off of the ice okay
hi everyone my name is Hannah before we
get started just a couple of bits of
information if you want to find me after
this talk on the Internet's I tend to
I'm at at tech girl Wonder I use she/her
pronouns I work for a company called
carbon 5 we are a product development
agency that works with all kinds of
clients from small startups to large
enterprises trying to help them take
their ideas from ideas into software we
are hiring and hireable so come find us
afterwards if you're interested in
that's the last you'll hear about that
this talk should come in around 30
minutes so there's maybe will be time
for questions so cool and the last thing
is it just a brief content warning this
talk does contain discussions of some
difficult topics including gender issues
mental illness drug use psychosis and
grief and loss if any of those make you
or a little too much for you I totally
respect the right to step out at any
point I will not there any judgement yes
okay let's go what's upon a time all you
needed to tell a story was a language
about a 40,000 years ago humans
committed the first story to a drawing
to art between four and five thousand
years ago the first story was committed
to writing this is a rendering of the
epic of gilgamesh one of the first known
written stories about 150 years ago the
first story was committed to film and
about 50 years ago a man named Marshall
McLuhan
I said that at this point the power of
the mediums themselves had surpassed the
stories in terms of their importance in
shaping our society he famously said the
medium is the message so my name is aunt
Hannah and I want to talk to you about
how programmers tell stories in code
because our medium is quite complicated
we spend a surprising amount of time
just learning the medium and trying to
get people able to use it and to be fair
the medium of code has shaped our
society drastically lots of other tops
of this conference will tell you just
how much but I believe that a good story
is as important as the medium we tell it
in and I think that if we as programmers
spent a fraction of the time we spend
learning our media learning instead
learning as well how to tell good
stories we could become much better
programmers so the goal of this talk is
to help you become a better programmer
and it's kind of aimed at people who
have made it into this industry just
made it in perhaps by kind of like
kicking the door down and you're here
now and you're trying to figure out now
what I've had a few hunches recently and
I'm not totally sure about these so just
fair at fair warning the first hunch is
that aside from my job title I actually
am a decent programmer it's only taken
20 years but I don't believe I suffer
from impostor syndrome the the second
hunch is that I might actually have
something useful to impart to you all
about about how to become better
programmers and the third is that the
best way for me to impart what I think I
know is to tell you my story into intact
of how I got into the tech to tech or
specifically for different stories of
how I got into tech if that sounds a
little bit odd just bear with me
and at the end I'd ask everyone to give
me your
feedback on whether this was what was
most and least valuable to you and your
in this talk okay part one you've
probably been asked this question you're
somewhere near the beginning of a
technical interview how did you get into
the tech industry this is how I answer
that question if I am in a job interview
I've been programming since I was really
young I
but after um uh sorry let me reset I've
been programming since I was really
young I got a degree in computer science
but when I left college I was really
idealistic and so I worked in nonprofits
for ten years before getting back into
tech sorry that is that's that's the
story I would give I have been
programming since I was really young I
actually started in junior high um and
part of the reason that I was drawn to
programming is that the basic mechanics
of programming were something that made
a lot of sense to me
I was I was quickly able to pick up
variables and loops and the sort of
imperative logic of Basic programming
was not I was good at that and when I've
taught code school I've seen that people
learn that stuff at pretty different
speeds right like there's actually a lot
of variation in how quickly people pick
up the mechanics um and I've been
thinking about the keynote yesterday and
how this variation in speed of picking
up the basics when you combine it with
this sort of like systematic refusal to
do traditional instruction and the kind
of like to help people get these basic
mechanics it creates this kind of
artificial barrier right we just expect
people you either get it or you don't
and then we take it a step further and
we look at people and we say that person
is a good programmer that person's not a
good programmer and that's based just on
whether they are a they are able to pick
up these mechanics but for me when I
think about that I think about if you
were asked to find the next great writer
and of the next generation you walked
into a second-grade classroom and you
just looked around and picked the kids
who are learning to read the fastest and
you said these are gonna be you know the
next Octavia Butler next you know
whomever that would be inaccurate right
so what I found out was pretty quickly I
found out I was not a great programmer
um I spent a year and a half trying to
write a 3d game engine to emulate what
was then the crowning achievement in
computer graphics a game called doom and
I could have failed I I mean I wrote
something it ran it looks sort of
similar but it just crashed about every
minute and at that time when it crashed
that meant the computer crashed and you
had to reboot it so um when I was
developing it and starting to work on
this really large project I found that I
was starting to get lost I couldn't even
remember half of the what half the files
even did the worst part is I thought I'd
done everything right right I did all
the things you were supposed to do I
unrolled my inner loops into assembler
so they could be faster
I used the hottest greatest
architectural techniques at the time
something called object-oriented
programming and the super new hotness
called class inheritance and it didn't
work it still didn't work a couple of
years later when I was in college the
doom source code was released and and
and I read it and it was it was kind of
boring it wasn't it wasn't that neat it
didn't seem to have any particularly
great architectural patterns it was
written in C not the super hot news C++
and the way that it was broken up
whereas we're kind of basic it wasn't
super well commented which I learned was
the way to write a sign of good code so
I only noticed one thing about it and
and that was that I could keep reading I
could kind of just like read a file and
follow along um and it was all kind of
consistent it made sense but I sort of
threw my hands up looking at the team
source code and it took me about 15
years to realize that I'd missed
something
this brings me to a slightly more honest
answer about how I got into the tech
industry I'd like to tell it to you now
after I graduated college at the age of
23 I decided to transition genders back
then transition was kind of a thing that
totally upended your life I lost my job
I was not an established programmer so I
ended up with minimal income and then I
ended up and then I found a career in
nonprofits and for a long time I
actually didn't think about tap it
sounds really sexist
to say this now but I believed at the
time the part of my transition was that
I simply could not be in a profession
that was that masculine it was only
years later when I read about other
women in tech that I got the courage to
dive back in now this is not a secret
story you have not been let in on a
great great secret most people who've
known me for some amount of time know
that I'm trans but I don't tell that
story to people in a job interview and
it's not because the other story is is
untrue it's just that I know my audience
who is the audience of a computer
program obviously we're talking to a
computer right that's one audience I was
taught at a very young age that a
computer program is a sequence of
instructions to tell a computer what to
do something right but the computer
could take those instructions in
directly in the language of ones and
zeros it does not care about
object-oriented programming it doesn't
care about functional programming it
doesn't care about declarative UI
components with the unidirectional data
flow or whatever the latest greatest of
hot techniques are I would I would throw
out there that if computers if they ever
become able to program themselves what
they will the programs that they will
write for themselves will look it will
be in a format that almost none of us
understand right so the audience of a
computer for our program
are the humans who have to build it and
who have to interact with it and who
have to maintain it this isn't really a
new idea but I feel like we constantly
lose sight of how central this is to
what we do almost everything we do in
programming down to even the concept of
variables is to help ourselves
understand not the computer why would I
adopt the current trends functional
programming immutable data structures
algebraic data types even maybe I get
into some crazy lambda calculus hotness
III like all those things but the reason
I adopt them is most likely because I
tried writing an imperative program and
I found that my human brain kind of
sucked at it right can you could you
tell what all this is going what's going
on here if you're if you can much much
respect to you you might know that it's
the go language because half the lines
are if R equals nil or not equals now
and waiting to get that go trolling or
the worst part is all right so this was
this sadly this is code that I shipped
like - like a month ago right this is
what I'm writing today because I'm
writing and go and this is really
complicated program and while this looks
like a mess it actually like is the
result of several iterations of making
sure it's exactly right and there are
more comments in the actual source code
but you write this really awesome
imperative thing you worked on it
forever and you show it to someone else
and they're like what the heck is this I
do not understand it so if we accept
that the audience of programming is
humans right then all we're doing to
some extent is trying to communicate
with each other through the medium of
code we are telling stories and so I
think it's kind of funny that we think
these like patterns are gonna solve us
solve all our problems
right if you imagine going to you walk
into a writer's workshop and there's a
vigorous argument going on and one side
of the room is like the key to writing
is to use similes and the other side is
like no the key to writing is to use
metaphors and they're fighting out it's
like it would be ridiculous
right I use these I tried patterns they
help but they didn't help a lot another
tool we have which I actually think is
weirdly potentially more useful in
certain cases is our frameworks right
our frameworks can could what they can
do is they can reduce the scope of the
complexity of the narrative we're trying
to tell by providing kind of like this
preset structure and the way I think of
this is if you if you think about like a
review of an action movie or a romantic
comedy right they'll say well the
story's really formulaic and I think the
frameworks are sort of the same thing
they provide you a good formula for
doing a certain set of things but then
the problem just like with an action
movie or a romantic comedy is that when
you try to do something new they kind of
leave you out on your own
so if our patterns are just patterns and
our frameworks are great but they don't
help you do something novel how do you
actually get good at programming so at
this point I would like to tell you the
real story of how I got into the tech
industry it goes like this
the realization that I wanted to
transition came from taking LSD and
before you wave it was before you get
think that I am a huge cheerleader for
psychedelics though I am I that
experience was was necessary but
extremely unpleasant um and it actually
led to me it was the beginning of a slow
and very intense mental unraveling that
ended with what as professionally called
an extreme psychotic break and that kind
of debilitated me for a few years for
three years I was out of work for five
years I was on government disability for
that time I carried the diagnosis of
schizoaffective disorder and when I
returned to work it was working
part-time in a clothing store before
later getting into nonprofits and much
later into tech
I don't tell that story to a lot of
people normally I guess now I have but
it's true and yet the other stories that
I've told you are also true each story
kappa they just leave things out and so
each story actually captures a different
truth for the person receiving it and
it's and I try to use tell the right
story to the right person receiving it
all of these stories actually encompass
oh sorry for the interview I tell the
story that is this like easily
digestible sound by eight but it has a
nice little nod about the nonprofit's
that makes it sound like I'm a
well-rounded person for people who know
me a bit the story of my transition kind
of humanizes me and it offers a bit of
understanding into Who I am it has this
nice little ending of like general
firming ending of like triumph over
adversity and the power of female role
models and all that and and this other
story is also a story of triumph over
adversity it's just a little bit more
messy it involves some topics that
aren't as fun to talk about because
people tend to make judgments about it
um but it actually has more value to me
um and it has more value because I know
that the adversity involved was actually
so much greater the trick here is
finding the right meaning for the
situation all three of these stories
cover about 15 years of my life so when
your aunt's when I'm answering it I kind
of have like a data compression problem
right like there there's way too much
information to answer in three sentences
all this different stuff so I have to
leave things out and and so then the
question is like what do we leave out
how do we decide what to leave out of a
narrative to give it meaning
so I accidentally took a graduate level
course in how to do this when during my
nonprofit career I ended up one of the
founders of a small nonprofit for
transgender people of color in Los
Angeles and I became accidentally our
unpaid grant writer like most
underfunded nonprofit groups that work
with multiple marginalized
populations our work was pretty messy we
did a lot of different things we helped
a lot of people we summarized didn't
help people when we should have it was
you know a lot of a lot of complexities
we had this approach which was we were
going to solve problems for people with
multiple oppressions that were hundreds
of years in the making with local issue
organizing campaigns in Los Angeles
which is a tall order ever ever there
was one we-we-we we did this we fought
through internal battle and strife and
whatnot
and then in order to get funding I had
to take all of that and I had to
compress it down into this like 8 page
narrative that was going to be given to
a foundation to evaluate whether to give
us money and that foundation was
probably a foundation that worked with
gay and lesbian communities honestly it
probably worked mostly with gay white
gay and lesbian communities they have
probably never funded transgender people
and they certainly had not funded a
group made up mostly of transgender
people of color what I learned to do in
grant writing was to seek the heart of
the truth in the moment and what that
means is I what I would do is I would
try to find a like one or two key
accomplishments that could go down to
like just a sentence or two that that
were really clear and then I would look
at kind of like the overall picture of
things and I would start to remove some
things that made things inconsistent not
like changing facts but just taking
things out that created inconsistency in
the narrative and what I would also do
is break apart different aspects of our
work into intersect into different
sections where each section told a
little mini story that made sense in and
of itself in fact what I was doing was I
was constructing like this system of
meaning through which someone who didn't
know much about the populations that we
served could look at this and understand
our work and it had an internal
consistency and it captured what was
important
so this sounds obvious a little bit
different than a software system but
maybe it's not if you are writing for a
startup how likely are you to build the
system a system that looks exactly like
it will in its final version how likely
are you to cover you know all of your
users needs better question how many
startups even know who their users are
and even more if even if they do know
who the users are how likely are the
users who like the product when it
starts going to be the same users who
like the product if it's widely
successful I think of most problems that
I'm working on in in in software as
being a little bit like this every
software system has to solve a
real-world problem otherwise I mean
there's not a lot of point in doing it
unless you are a pure mathematician and
real-world problems are big and
confusing right and they don't have
closed ends to them and so every one of
the solutions you write in software is
partial right you just solve one little
thing that's the core and you think
there's a bunch of other things here not
so you know there's a bunch of other
things you're not solving but the really
interesting thing is you there's a whole
bunch of things you don't even know
you're not solving right the actual
problem space is probably bigger than
you know so the way I learned to write
grants to do this process was through
practice feedback and revision that's
what they do in writers workshops they
read each other's stories and they give
individual feedback so it was just a
process of kind of getting better slowly
with lots of feedback and this is
probably the most disappointing part of
the prop the talk when you're waiting
for the three steps to becoming a great
to becoming a better programmer and the
problem is there are no steps right
there's just this individual feedback
and revision loop we almost never get
our code right on the first try even if
it runs it probably doesn't make a lot
of sense to
someone reading it and we probably have
to go back and change it and so the
practices that I have leaned on over the
long term are the ones that build the
feedback loop into the process of
programming itself the things that I
tend to gravitate towards over time or
testing and pair programming kind of the
standard agile stuff but what I love
about them is the assumed revision and
refactor is a core part of the process
of writing code it's not something you
do three months later when you have
tacked up um and I think it's also
interesting that we have these prizes
somebody will give you advice like if
you're stuck take a break and go for a
walk right
what happens there well in some way what
we're doing what we're saying when we
the reason that works is we're
acknowledging that there's a certain
creative component to the coding process
and there is a little bit of an
inspiration that just strikes when you
step away from the computer
so come towards the conclusion and I
hope that I am NOT leaving you you're
probably feeling a little disappointed
because it seems like our moral is to be
a good programmer keep practicing that's
not good that's not an answer I'm super
excited about so I'd like to leave you
with one more story then maybe one more
tool to maybe make it a little bit
better so I've been thinking about my
story getting into programming and I've
been reminding myself of some parts that
I leave out even to myself a lot of the
time so here are those parts so I was
born on two wealthy parents I had access
to computers at a very young age and I
had a lot of resources and this this fed
into my year you know my when I had all
of these challenges with mental illness
my mom actually took a whole year off of
work just to take care of me and that
was something she could do and and
honestly while I was on government
disability I had my parents also
sometimes supplemented my income so I
had all of the support they even
eventually accepted my gender and as I
was moving through those worlds when I
was still struggling with this when I
was moving through the mental health
world and the trans world I wouldn't
counter people who were struggling with
almost the same things I was but they
didn't have the resources right and
their outcomes were not good honestly I
have two two of my best friends from my
20s passed away in their early thirties
so my story is one of struggle and
triumph but it's also one of privilege
and also something called survivor's
guilt the feeling of why was I allowed
to make it I leave out the whole truth
but if I leave out this part of the
truth and I get attached to this idea of
just every new situation is adversity
and struggle and overcome and overcoming
it it's it it it forces me to confront
life in a specific way and not every
situation in life is like that all of us
tell stories to ourselves both to
ourselves and to other people if you've
never had to think about your story or
tell it to someone in a way that left a
couple parts out I don't want to assume
too much but you may be coming from a
pretty intense position of privilege I
have this harebrained belief that
marginalized folks are often some of the
best programmers and the reason is I
think that is that marginalized people
have this experience of constantly
changing and revising our own stories
and battle testing them so we can sort
of force people to listen to them in a
world that doesn't necessarily want to
hear our stories but my therapist says I
do have a therapist that our stories are
just stories they they're only valuable
in terms of the truth they tell about
the present moment and so she says it's
it's best to hold them lightly to be
willing to let go of your stories and
rewrite them whenever it feels
appropriate and if I had a parting piece
of advice about how to become a good
programmer it would be to take the
process lightly it'd be willing to
constantly try new ideas
techniques and when they're not working
for you let them go right if you're into
functional programming but at some point
it doesn't feel right
let it go try something new learning is
made much easier I think when you let go
of your sense of perfectionism the truth
is that after twenty years of
programming when I go to work I just try
to do the best job that I can for that
day I try to make today's narrative make
sense I tried to write as awesome a
story in whatever context I'm in for
eight hours and then I throw it out and
start again the next day thank you
oh no we have to have four questions
shoot I mean yeah if anyone has
questions yeah
yeah go for it of the illustrations yes
oh my god
yeah so I made those illustrations it's
I'm really excited about yeah okay so
there's this crazy thing called the iPad
and it's pretty wild
because ah god I'd sound like a total
Apple like advertisement here but um I I
mean like I've I've okay at art but I'm
not like you know like I never
considered myself an artist that that
I've had man it it with a pet you you
put a pencil on that and you can do
things you would not have thought I mean
a lot of it is done with um taking an
image and then tracing and drawing over
it that helps cuz the thing I'm kind of
the least good with is the like getting
the lines right so yeah yes go ahead
yes you in the green sorry
mm-hmm
I I'd like to think so
I I'm still I mean there's probably
another talk about the other side of
this which is like how to become a
better teacher and a mentor right that
is similarly at least in my experience
based on a lot of practice and revision
and trying different things um I I found
that well so I were gonna come in it
does a lot of pair programming and so I
do a lot of mentoring through pair
programming and unfortunately for the
last year I've been like heads down on
this go project where I've done very
little mentoring uh I think though that
like I'm trying to figure out something
that I've been thinking about is like
you know could you build an actual like
lesson around software architecture and
I think it would be interesting to give
people like a problem a contained
problem that could you know people
who've been programming for two three
years not like not this is not like I
how to get into programming exercise get
folks who've been programming for two
three years like a contained software
problem that you could solve and you
know like three four hours right and
then actually look at a roomful of
solutions and talk about each other
solutions so that's something that I
would like to try and certainly when I
am working with folks well I mean what I
guess what I most what I often will say
is like well you know like what does
that code mean and can you make that
meeting more clear you know like and
some of that comes from like the way my
mom taught me to write which was very
intense like she heard her method was to
look at like a paper and just go this
doesn't make sense
you know like and so I feel like but I
so I try to do that in a slightly more
compassionate way but I don't feel like
I'm an expert on mentoring just to be
clear I'm still trying to think figure
that out
yeah yes
hmm yeah no no uh well I I think that oh
sorry so sorry sorry how can we get
better at get at telling stories
I don't know like I would say my telling
stories started with telling jokes right
like I like to tell people like little
opinions and ideas about life and maybe
drawn from an experience or two and
that's like the simplest thing I think
honestly the way we start telling
stories is talking to each other I
wouldn't like I mean if you like writing
maybe write journal a little bit try
that I'm actually someone was was
talking about journaling as a good
method to like deal with your first or
second year of coding which i think is
really interesting because it is that
reflecting I think that the way you get
to be a better storyteller is to reflect
on your own experience which a lot of us
do but like sometimes we don't do it
that intentionally and if you get
developed the habit of like actually
recording what happened and what that
meant to you in them in that moment I
think you'll get a little that'll help
maybe get you to be a better storyteller
you come out to Los Angeles there's a
whole city full of people trying to
figure that out I don't really but I'm
not part of them so yeah go ahead
yes
yes I think so I mean I guess all of our
stories end with death but like that's
that's it sorry I apologize I was like
well where does the story end
okay well it's when you die I guess
sorry um
I'm just thinking about that like as so
the question is is there let me see if I
understood the question the question is
is there more meaning of our stories yet
to be revealed even though they are
often about memories in the past is that
right yeah yes sure yeah I mean so so
somebody I was somebody was I was
talking to somebody yesterday and they
were like well do you mean just like
denying your own memories and I was like
no not really
right like here's the thing that I
something that I what I know of memory
is that my understanding is that our
memories of events that have happened
are not actually all that accurate often
they're they like as soon as something
happens we remember it in a slightly
different way in our minds particularly
because what actually makes it to the
like the frontal cortex is like just a
small sliver of what's going on and I
think so when you when you when you look
at that the basic events don't change
right like all the things that have
happened have happened but you the
meanings that we assigned to them this
happened and that meant something that
meant this and even more intense that
meant this about me right
like about Who I am as a person like all
of that is to some extent yours to
reassign right and I think we keep
reassigning that even as I was writing
this this talk I was I was on a trip for
a client in Europe and just the past
year too I got to fly internationally
for code which was I know it's silly but
it was really exciting like to get to to
get to do something like that and it was
like this weird thing where I was like
well now it's interesting because I have
this whole story in my talk but now I'm
kind of experiencing what it's like to
move
the world in a way that I didn't for my
20s 30s or anything you know um
and so yeah and so who we are
continually changes and you should be
able to let to constantly change that I
don't think it's worth getting too
attached into an idea of who you are in
a given moment I mean like I was a
pretty antisocial nerdy person at one
point I'm not that person usually
anymore so not sorry that's not like a
statement of overcoming but you know
it's just sort of like people sometimes
people will tell me oh you're so
extroverted and that makes me awkward
because I'm like I'm not extroverted how
dare you anyway we have four minutes
left well I left like a while well at it
yeah no okay well if there are no more
questions that wait wait wait wait sorry
sorry continue yes question
sure
I mean in this context I'm mostly
talking this is about the audience for
code itself not the product like to some
extent I mean obviously that the product
itself shapes the code and one I think
one of the biggest mistakes you can make
as a programmers to get focused on the
code for the codes sake and not for the
problem at solving but um but I also I'm
talking about how we write code that we
can work on and other people can work on
and we can maintain and grow over time
my sense is that most of the problems
that we have in software that lead to
most of the bugs I mean they're not
really the machines fault right like
mostly the machine is pretty consistent
in doing what you asked it to the
problem is that we're not like it just
is not a language that we like naturally
understand so we're building all these
systems to make it easier for ourselves
to understand it in such a way that we
don't introduce bugs into the software I
mean even like something like functional
programming like I actually really love
it but the reason that like mutating
data everywhere is bad is not because
it's fundamentally bad for the Machine
it's bad because it makes it harder for
us to remember because our memory is not
that great for that type of thing to
remember where we changed something that
could be causing a problem so yeah is
that helpful
all right oh yes one more question
oh yeah error not equals no I realize I
said that wrong yes yeah oh for sure
yeah yeah um so I well air equals that's
go which I would say is not really
that's more like imperative ish
programming my experience with selling
functional programming is uh this is
really terrible but the short version is
the in the moment you mentioned you know
abstract algebra category theory terms
people tend to tune out
I always introduce it man Gary Gary
Bernhardt gave a talk here at strangely
like three years ago but he has this
thing where he doesn't record stops and
it's like the his basic point was like
he's sucking really about immutability
and I think that that's the core of
functional programming everything else
is about like building stuff on top of
that and how to deal with the fact you
have to have side effects in the program
but I think that when I think about
functional programming I always think
about it's really about copying data
rather than mutating it because by doing
that you kind of do this built-in
ability to have you introduce a layer of
predictability into your to your code
and I really like that about functional
programming into some except this talk
is a bit of a reaction on my part to my
own like obsession with it to the point
where I'm like you know what I'm pretty
sure that you cannot reduce software or
to a mathematically provable problem
right I mean that would be nice if we
could get there but I feel like the
problem is that software exists in the
real world and in the real world has
humans involved and so software as well
has to work for humans and they tend to
do things you don't predict I mean it
the most intense level you know you have
all the hardware that could fail at any
given moment which is always interesting
to me I go to Erlang conferences and I'm
always like well what happens if like
the power the server center experiences
a power outage and they're in there UPS
doesn't have a backup or something like
that and you know how do you keep it how
do you get the nine nines uptime and
they're like yeah well you know well we
had we try to figure that one out in the
moment
I'm like okay well there's still problem
there yeah
anyway cool all right that's all I got
Thanks
[Applause]